[Music]
so today after weeks of being smeared by
Democrats called evil accused of rape
and gang rape being compared to Bill
Cosby
after weeks of vile death threats
against his family after weeks of being
demonized all over television and in
most major newspapers well today Brett
Kavanaugh finally had a chance under
oath to clear his good name dramatic
testimony today powerful testimony watch
this this confirmation process has
become a national disgrace the
Constitution gives the Senate an
important role in the confirmation
process but you have replaced advice and
consent with Search and Destroy
since my nomination in July there's been
a frenzy on the left to come up with
something anything to block my
confirmation shortly after I was
nominated the Democratic Senate leader
said he would quote oppose me with
everything he's got a Democratic senator
on this committee publicly publicly
referred to me as evil given comments
like those is it any surprise that
people have been willing to do anything
to make any physical threat against my
family to send any violent email to my
wife to make any kind of allegation
against me and against my friends to
blow me up and take me down you sowed
the wind for decades to come
I fear that the whole country will reap
the whirlwind
judge Cavanaugh also had this to say
about the process and his family and
what they have been forced to endure
again with zero corroboration no
presumption of innocence no due process
what's this the behavior of several the
Democratic members of this committee of
my hearing a few weeks ago was an
embarrassment but at least it was just a
good old-fashioned attempt at working
those efforts didn't work when I did at
least okay enough
at the hearings that it looked like I
might actually get confirmed a new
tactic was needed some of you were lying
in wait and had it ready
this first allegation was held in secret
for weeks by a Democratic member of this
committee and by staff it would be
needed only if you couldn't take me out
on the merits when it was needed this
allegation was unleashed and publicly
deployed over dr. Ford's wishes this
whole two-week effort has been a
calculated and orchestrated political
hit fueled with apparent pent-up anger
about President Trump and the 2016
election fear that has been unfairly
stoked about my judicial record revenge
on behalf of the Clintons and millions
of dollars in money from outside
left-wing opposition groups this is a
circus the consequences will extend long
past my nomination the consequences will
be with us for decades and after those
powerful remarks judge Kavanagh
addressed his accuser professor
Christine Ford take a look at this
emotional moment from earlier today I
have never done this to her or to anyone
that's not who I am it is not who I was
I am innocent of this charge I intend no
ill will to dr. Ford and her family the
other night Ashley and my daughter Liza
said their prayers and little Liza all
10 years old
said to Ashley we should pray for the
woman it's a lot of wisdom from the
ten-year-old we're here they're not my
radio show a lot of people around me
guys girls they all were crying
ten-year-old little girl powerful moment
and she's absolutely right but let's
take a moment to review the charges from
Professor Ford or allegations were made
in July to a Democratic member of
Congress she claims well
those claims come back 36 years nearly
four decades and I I've been saying she
deserved to be heard from the very
beginning these allegations are serious
they were taken seriously by the
president by the Senate and by everybody
except and I'll explain but she doesn't
remember a date day of the week location
how she got to or from the party where
the alleged crime took place all four
witnesses that Professor Ford listen
listed to corroborate her claims they
all deny what she is alleging all four
in sworn statements under penalty of
felony
let me repeat all witnesses have given
sworn statements under the penalty of
felony that means you can go to jail to
the Democrats what that means is this
has been investigated the people that
were there have already spoken in an
includes professor Ford's friend her
name Leland Kaiser her attorney released
the statement it reads quote simply put
miss Kaiser does not know mr. Cavanaugh
and has no recollection of ever being at
a party or gathering where he was
present with or without dr. Ford today
the Senate's independent prosecutor
asked her about this irrefutable fact
take a look are you aware that they say
that they have no memory or knowledge of
such a party yes do you have any
particular motives to ascribe to Leland
I guess we could take those one at a
time
Leland has significant health challenges
and I'm happy that she's focusing on
herself and getting the health treatment
that she needs and
she let me know that she needed her
lawyer to take care of this for her and
she texted me right afterward with an
apology and good wishes and etc so I'm
glad that she's taking care of herself
today's testimony from Professor Ford
actually raised more questions and
answered including this moment about
Ford's recent polygraph test let's take
a look at this why was that location
chosen for the polygraph I had left my
grandmother's funeral at Fort Lincoln
Cemetery that day and was on tight
schedule to get a plane to Manchester
New Hampshire so he was willing to come
to me which was appreciated so he
administered a polygraph on the day that
you attended your grandmother's you know
yeah correct
or bit might have been the next day I
spent the night in the hotel so the
exact day did you pay for the polygraph
yourself I don't I don't I don't think
so okay do you know who did pay for the
polygraph not yet no I believe he said
it hasn't been paid for yet is that
correct
let me put an ends at this ministry her
lawyers have paid for her polygraph as
is routine as is routine is it your
understanding that someone else is going
to assist you with some of these fees
including the cost for your polygraph
I'm aware that there's been several
GoFundMe sites that I haven't had a
chance to figure out how to manage those
because I've never had one now just to
recap professional for doesn't remember
when the incident in question happened
she doesn't remember where the incident
happened she's given inconsistent
answers about this important detail she
doesn't remember exactly who attended
the party in question she's given
inconsistent answers about this detail
she doesn't remember how she got to the
alleged party she doesn't remember how
she got back from the party and not one
person corroborates her story
we also learned today that she doesn't
remember if she handed though Washington
Post therapy notes just a few weeks ago
now in minutes just minutes ago the Wall
Street Journal editorial board fully
endorsed the confirmation of Judge Brett
Kavanaugh and also moments ago we
learned that senator Mitch McConnell
announced the Judicial Committee the
Senate Judicial Committee will in fact
Judiciary Committee in the morning they
are moving forward he said and moments
ago senator bob Corker a tennessee
announced on twitter that he will vote
YES on Brett Kavanaugh but none of this
matters seemingly to people on the other
side it shouldn't be about Republican or
Democrat liberal conservative at all
they wanted and stated from the
beginning they wanted a roon judge Brett
Kavanaugh and over unsubstantiated
uncorroborated claims from nearly four
decades ago for the left at this point
it's not about sexual misconduct
otherwise they'd be talking about keith
ellison they would have had more harsh
statements about Bill Clinton this has
not been about protecting victims or
finding the truth even to them from day
one Chuck Schumer leading the way this
has all been political it is a sad day
for the country what we had to witness
today the worst part of this is Senator
Dianne Feinstein knew about these claims
since July she knew about these charges
when she actually met with Kavanaugh in
private she knew about these claims
which he questioned him during his
public hearing several weeks ago and
when she met privately with Brett
Kavanaugh she had already been
recommending attorneys to Professor Ford
only after Brett Kavanaugh was
nomination looked imminent did Dianne
Feinstein and Democrats announced Ford's
allegations this has been a disgraceful
display of politics at its worst is
reelection more important than another
person's life here did anybody hear the
pain and Brett Kavanaugh his voice today
and by the way I would argue to
Professor Ford as Susan Collins has said
nobody's been served well here she
wished to remain anonymous the story got
leaked her name got leaked and without
any corroboration or evidence then you
had
politician smearing Cavanaugh again and
again on national TV this is but a small
sampling take a look the Senate
shouldn't simply rely on hearing two
conflicting accounts and decide well
we're okay with not knowing we're okay
with the fact that we might be putting a
someone who committed attempted rape on
the Supreme Court of United States I
believe her listen first of all anybody
who comes forward at this point to be
prepared to testify in the United States
Senate against someone who's being
nominated to one of the most powerful
positions of the United States
government that takes an extraordinary
amount of courage not only do women like
dr. Ford who bravely comes forward need
to be heard but they need to be believed
they need to be believed I just want to
say to the men in this country just shut
up and step up do the right thing let me
just say right at the outset I believe
dr. Ford I believe the survivor here
there's every reason to believe her she
has come forward courageously and
bravely I believe her I stand with her
she should be bullied into this scenario
where it's a he-said she-said it's a
sham hearing and I don't think she
should participate in it I believe
professor Ford I think she's credible
and I think when the investigation is
finished and when she testifies and
judge Kavanagh testifies I think a
majority of senators will find her
credible and the smears continued during
the hearing and today Democrats ramping
up their favorite new talking point we
must have an FBI investigation now this
is of course all a political stall
tactic they want to delay delay delay
they hope we get to the midterms they
hope they win and they hope they stop
Donald Trump from fulfilling a campaign
promise and a constitutional obligation
watch the echo chamber and on the other
side of this I'm going to explain why
this is phony and they know it
take a look at the behavior of several
the Democratic members of this
committee of my hearing a few weeks ago
was an embarrassment but at least it was
just a good old-fashioned attempt at
barking those efforts didn't work when I
did at least okay enough that the
hearings that it looked like I might
actually get confirmed a new tactic was
needed some of you were lying in wait
and had it ready
this first allegation was held in secret
for weeks by a democratic member of this
committee and by staff it would be
needed only if you couldn't take me out
on the merits when it was needed this
allegation was Unleashed and publicly
deployed over dr. Ford's wishes this
whole two-week effort has been a
calculated and orchestrated political
hit fueled with a parent pent up anger
about president Trump and the 2016
election fear that has been unfairly
stoked about my judicial record revenge
on behalf of the Clintons and millions
of dollars in money from outside
left-wing opposition groups this is a
circus the consequences will extend long
past my nomination the consequences will
be with us for decades now an FBI
investigation does not make conclusions
they all knew this it would interview
everybody that has already been
interviewed and a report would then be
issued that's it
the Democrats know it in 1991
then-senator Joe Biden suggested that
these FBI investigations are actually
useless his words and they all agreed
back then take a look the next person
refers to an FBI report as being worth
anything obviously doesn't understand
anything FBI
explicitly does not in this or any other
case reach a conclusion period period so
judges no reason why you should know
this the reason why we cannot rely on
the FBI report you wouldn't like it if
we did because it is in conclusive
they say he said she said and they said
period so when people wave an FBI report
before you understand they do not they
do not they do not reach conclusions
they do not make as my friend points out
more attic they do not make
recommendations
remember all witnesses all in this case
gave sworn statements under the threat
of felony Democrats have turned this
important process into a political sham
they have termed advise and consent
in to destroy malign they can't care
whose life is destroyed in this process
obviously they don't did they not see
what went on today to judge Cavanaugh
the impact on him his family the women
making these allegations as they
withheld them for all those weeks they
just want Cavanaugh stopped at all costs
today no one seems to put this in better
perspective than Senator Lindsey Graham
what was a powerful moment when he took
on the Democrats take a look what you
want to do is destroy this guy's life
hold this seat open and hope you win in
2020 you said that not me you've got
nothing to apologize for when you see
soda Meyer and cake and tell them that
Lindsey said all because I voted for
them I would never do to them what
you've done to this guy this is the most
unethical sham since I've been in
politics I cannot imagine what you and
your family are going through boy y'all
want power god I hope you never get it I
hope the American people can see through
this sham that you knew about it and you
held it you had no intention of
protecting dr4 none she's as much of a
victim as you are god I hate to say it
cuz these have been my friends but let
me tell you when
comes to this you're looking for a fair
process you came to the wrong town
at the wrong time my friend to my
Republican colleagues if you vote no
you're legitimizing the most despicable
thing I have seen in my time in politics
senator Graham will join us in studio in
just a moment and after those passionate
remarks senator Orrin Hatch called these
proceedings worse than any other
confirmation proceedings in history
including those of judge Bork and judge
Thomas let's watch this the circus
atmosphere that has been created since
my democratic colleagues first leaked
dr. Ford's allegations to the media two
weeks ago after sitting on them for six
weeks my my dad has brought us the worst
in our politics
it certainly has brought us no closer to
the truth
anonymous letters with no name and no
return address are not being treated as
national news porn star Lord lawyers
with facially implausible claims are
driving the news cycle I hate to say
this but this is worse than Robert Bork
and I didn't think it could get any
worse than that this is worse than
Clarence Thomas I didn't think it could
get any worse than that
this is a national disgrace the way
you're being treated this is sadly the
Democratic playbook I warm people every
single two years every four years on my
radio show and right here on this show
Republicans be prepared to be demonized
racist sexist misogynist xenophobic
homophobic Islamophobic you want dirty
air water you want to kill children and
there'll be some Paul Ryan look-alike
throwing your grandmother over the cliff
because Republicans want granny to die
and it's the same now with Supreme Court
nominees same predictable behavior we've
now come to expect this this has to
change this country deserves better the
people of this country deserve better
these people in DC in this swamp they
are supposed to serve us you we the
people it's not about a Republican
Democrat liberal or conservative here
this is
or human decency that was in play today
they destroyed this man and his family
they bludgeoned him all for the sake of
power
there was zero presumption of innocence
here or due process now the Democratic
Party every two four years every time we
have a nomination of the Supreme Court
we know it to expect the party of
slander besmirched in smears character
assassination the party of no due
process no presumption of innocence the
party that rushes to judgment look at
all the high profile cases rush to
judgment Duke Lacrosse case the
Cambridge police acted stupidly Ferguson
Missouri Baltimore Maryland Richard
Jewell Trayvon Martin is this the party
that's going to decide the fate of this
country because in 40 days that same
party wants you to go out and vote for
them look at your screen you see these
Republican senators these are the people
who will decide the fate of the
Cavanaugh nomination right there those
are the people that will decide if we
still have due process in this country
if these principles exist in this
country if we still have laws predicated
on the Constitution let them know how to
vote call them tell them what's at stake
let them know what you felt today
watching these hearings and if you're in
one of these states where Donald Trump
won West Virginia Joe Manchin North
Dakota Heidi Heitkamp Indiana Joe
Donnelly your Democratic senators up for
re-election they don't confirm judge
Cavanaugh and they go along with the
smear campaign if they go ahead and do
that are you gonna vote for them now
there is a lot in the next few days
weeks and months that we're going to
decide and we have a lot to get to in
the course of this program tonight I
just want to say what we're looking at
right here tonight what you're looking
at you get to hold them accountable for
their decisions never as a Supreme Court
nomination but more important this
country is at a tipping point
inalienable rights of Americans they're
going to continue or we are going to
never be able to go
back our Constitution all these core
principles hang in the balance tonight
and we have one party that has thrown
all of this to the wind and adopted
smear slander personal politics of
destruction unless good senators find a
backbone and stick up for these core
fundamental rights of every human being
like we've been talking about due
process justice law order Democrats take
down judge Cavanaugh a man with
impeccable with an impeccable record of
service 40 year track record they can
take down anybody any conservative any
politician for any reason on any
allegation with zero proof ever the
Senate cannot let this happen
they cannot reward this behavior